it's not gonna be the same here without  you Bridgewater will be watching when  four-bath pulls of Walsh in the  wild-card see you on the field soon  teddy  Andrew uh nobody has any idea what's  wrong with you or if you'll even play  again that's okay  [Music]  dear fellows I can't believe how fast  things moved on the outside seems like  the world when it got itself in one big  hurry up offense I saw up touchdown  celebration once when I was a kid but  now they everywhere I was 22 then I'm 24  now I remember when Los Angeles was just  the place teams threatened to move to  now they got a team in a half and nobody  seems to care  some days I think I should just take a  cheap shot from Fletcher Cox oh they'll  send me home to the house but just when  I thought the league and asked me back I  realized some things never change